hey guys Pete here so it's working on
some other stuff that I've taught this
LC thing the other day and I wanted to
go ahead and make a video about that
first before I finish the other two
projects I'm working on this video is
going to be about what might have
happened to LC and to a lesser extent
Stubbs and it will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in Westworld
season 1 so a couple days ago I saw on
reddit that there were some changes to
the delos Incorporated website when you
go there now the home page is all
scrambled up but there's still the admin
log in there so someone figured out by
talking to the chat bot aidan on the
other website that the word reverie was
a good thing to try for the admin login
when you put it in the box this is what
you see
you
you
that string in numbers is hexadecimal or
hex and if you translate that into text
you get something that's called base64
when you convert that you actually get
two links the first is to a video that
shows the location of Elsie's tablet you
can see that she's in Sector 20 or I
should say that her tablets there so I'm
not sure where sector 20 is I know that
it's not the secret sector that was
number 17 where Ford has his cottage and
all that and obviously it doesn't mean
that she's alive it just means that her
tablet shows up but why would they make
this video and then hide it in the
website like this if it's not a clue to
that she's still around somehow so it's
definitely an interesting fine then the
first video just gives us a clue that
we're gonna find out more about Elsie
and further those of us that are big
Elsie fans you know we have something to
think about until the next season the
second link is a little bit different
but it might even be more important but
again it's just a clue it's pretty vague
overall it's an audio clip so I'll let
it play and then you guys can tell me
what you think about it
so that definitely sounds like her voice
and she says hello so what do we think
makes sense for what happened - L see
I've been reading different things and I
went back and I watched some different
scenes with her in it I mean there's no
doubt about it they set her up to be an
important character she's right below
Bernard who is Ford's right-hand man it
just doesn't make sense that they would
build the characters up and then have
them die sort of unceremoniously
off-screen there's actually an article
that came out in Entertainment Weekly
where the two show runners were asked
the question directly
the interviewer points out that both of
them could have been useful in this end
part especially Stubbs whenever it came
to the uprising and Jonathan Nolan and
Lisa joy answered like this look we
loved working with Luke and Shannon they
were early incarnations where we tied up
those arcs in the finale
I'm not saying how I'm just saying we
tied them up I wouldn't say tied them up
I would say we unspooled them in an
uncertain future where we elucidated
their fate more explicitly but their
fates we know where they're going and
we'll get them there Nolan finishes by
saying we dearly love both those actors
we also you know it was not our
intention to spend out huge mysteries ad
infinitum we wanted to resolve some
pretty important storytelling but we
didn't want to answer every question so
going back and rewatching some of the LC
scenes as they relate to knowing that
Ford was actually trying to have the
host wake up and be able to stand on
their own she was actually a pretty
important character on first watch she
just seems like she's there to push
things along with Bernard but there are
a couple times when you can tell that
she actually has a real interest in the
host development I mean it's it's
superficially about how they are in the
park but she's clearly smarter than the
average person about how things work and
then there's a couple weird scenes that
don't make any sense
like when she kisses Clementine in the
first episode and then later she seems
to feel real sympathy for the Loras in
that scene in the street before she puts
her in sleep mode she also
seems to be really competent and
probably is the third most useful coder
after Bernard and Ford himself so we're
all familiar with the scene with Bernard
choking her and I think there's a real
possibility that Ford was being honest
whenever he said that he never had
Bernard hurt anyone else like that all
we see is him choke her if Ford did have
him kill her he could have just told
Bernard about it and then rolled him
back the reveries themself is what
brought that memory back so Ford might
not have realized that that was what was
causing Bernard the trouble either way
there's a couple scenarios where she
doesn't die at the end of that the first
which I think makes the most sense is
that she was just being put in a
chokehold that was supposed to knock her
out not kill her the second would be
that she realized when she was looking
at the tablet before he got there that
he was actually a host and then was able
to use voice commands to stop him those
would have two different outcomes of
course I mean if she stopped him with
voice commands then she probably escaped
into the park somewhere but if he choked
her out then she was probably put
somewhere for safekeeping
one thing that I checked when I was
watching is that a lot of people asked
in the comments wasn't she on the phone
with him right before she got choked and
the answer is no if you go back and
watch that episode you'll see that they
end their phone conversation with her
saying that she's gonna download the
rest of the information and then meet
him at his office then it cuts to a
different scene and there would have
been plenty of times for him to get
there and to choke her out I think that
takes off the option of it being Arnold
and not Bernard because I think that the
finale pretty much made it clear that
Arnold did die and you know before the
park ever open I'll be interested to
hear what you guys think in the comments
about that but I think it the most
straightforward answer is the the right
one Ford knew she was valuable to the
park after the red wedding if you will
the gala where they killed everyone off
so he probably had her put somewhere
safe until the whole thing died out and
that would make a lot of sense with
Stubbs - he was the one that was
actually smart enough to be skeptical
about how safe the host actually were he
carried a real gun and he was ready to
use it pretty much and he even went to
the extreme of saying that he slept with
it under his pillow the whole story of
him being led
to sector 17 where Ford's host family
lives and where there's no service to
connect to the network and all that I
mean that just reeks of for trying to
neutralize the guy because he could be a
potential problem whenever things went
down he could also have been looking at
him like he'll be a good resource for
whenever the dust settles and then you
know they'll have to move forward with
the park after killing the entire board
some people like the theory that LC was
out there and she's the one who caught
stub so that they could you know join
forces I guess you could say I think
it's a lot more likely that forward
coordinating it but you know there's
definitely a chance that they are
working together and they're just sort
of waiting things out either way it'll
be pretty interesting next season to see
where those two characters are which i
think we can sell from the interview
with the showrunners that will
definitely find that out and they'll
play a big role in the future one thing
I noticed when I was rewatching the
scene at the theater was that when she's
looking at her tablet she she finds
something really big we don't know what
it is but if you zoom in you could see
that it looks like she's looking at the
lorises profile on the screen I'm not
sure what that means but it's definitely
there for a reason so this could support
the idea that she found out that Barnard
was a host or that there's been big
changes to Dolores that's gonna cause
this whole thing at the end but we
really don't know how that plays into
things until we know how she ended up
getting out of that theater which was
not in a body bag as far as I'm
concerned there are people who think
that it might be that she was killed and
he was making her replacement as a host
but Jonathan Nolan did say in an
interview that that host being made when
Theresa there was just for a dramatic
effect like he made a point of it so and
that if that's the case then it wouldn't
be misdirection it'd be an outright lie
that he lied to us about what that is
therefore he could have just said you'll
find out later or something like that
but he said it was basically nothing
that was just there as a prop so let me
know what you guys think in the comments
this is the all the evidence I could
find I'm in the camp that they're both
still alive Stubbs and LC and they're
both
back to play a role I'm not a hundred
percent sure what that'll be so let's
talk about it and let's see what we come
up with I'm still thinking about doing
the Q&A and with a couple other
Westworld videos but I'm gonna be back
on Game of Thrones for the next couple
days so if you have questions that you
want me to address leave them in the
comments make sure you like the video
and please subscribe to my channel
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon